SIERRA: What does it take to make a hit in
Hollywood? An a-list actress? A tried-and-true
superhero franchise? How about... the blessing
of the People’s Republic of China. For years
now, Hollywood has been straining to make
sure its films don’t offend Chinese censors.
Without their approval, studios can’t gain
access to China’s massive box office. Pleasing
Chinese censors can mean adding scenes that
glorify the country, but it can also mean
leaving things out, particularly anything
that calls attention to human rights abuses.
The financial pressures to do so have gotten
so intense that in many cases American filmmakers
are pre-empting censorship altogether, and
designing their films to pass muster from
the first draft. I’m Gabrielle Sierra, and
this is Why It Matters, today, China in the
director’s chair.
SIERRA: So, what does China have to do with
Hollywood?
TAGER: So this is a particularly important
year for the China-Hollywood relationship
because this is the year that the Chinese
box office is expected to surpass the American
box office as the most important box office
in the world.
SIERRA: This is James Tager. He is Deputy
Director of Free Expression Research and Policy
at PEN America, and the author of the PEN
America report, Made in Hollywood, Censored
by Beijing.
TAGER: Now, to get access to that box office,
any movie studio, and this includes Hollywood,
has to go through a regulatory process set
up by Beijing, set up by the Chinese government.
The issue is that this regulatory process
includes censorship, that compliance with
China's censorship model is a prerequisite
to entering the Chinese market. So what we've
seen increasingly is Hollywood studios, firstly,
complying with the censorship and editing
or altering or removing content that Chinese
censors object to. But increasingly, we're
seeing a sort of more proactive compliance,
an anticipatory compliance and a self censorship,
basically removing things that studios even
suspect will upset the Chinese censor. And
beyond that sort of working more actively
with Chinese censors and Chinese government
officials to include portrayals of China or
to include portrayals that the Chinese government
particularly likes within their movies.
SIERRA: In many cases altered content only
affects the versions that are sent to theaters
in China. But in other cases these changes
are included in the global release too, meaning
that American audiences, and audiences all
over the world, are sometimes watching propaganda
without even knowing it. It’s shocking when
you think about it for a second, and seems
to undermine a lot of what Hollywood stands
for. So...why are they doing it?
TAGER: Hollywood studios, like any other foreign
studios, in this situation, really have significant
economic imperatives to cooperate with this
Chinese model of censorship in order to get
into the country. And this is perhaps most
pronounced when we look at Hollywood's biggest
movies, the blockbusters, the movies that
everyone sees, you know, movies like Iron
Man 3, where Chinese censors were actually
invited to the set to kind of see what was
going on.
Iron Man 3: (Movie Scene)
SIERRA: Released way back in 2013, Iron Man
3 grossed $1.2 billion worldwide. Of that,
it made $409 million domestically, and $121
million in China. That’s a huge chunk of
change. And the proportion of profits coming
from China continues to grow.
TAGER: There is a quota system that is in
place, where the Chinese government will allow
up to 34 movies from outside the country.
Technically, they can bend the rules on this
a little bit, but usually the number is 34.
Many of these spots are obtained by Hollywood
Studios with their biggest blockbusters and
access or lack thereof to the Chinese market
for these big big movies can literally make
or break the profitability of a certain Hollywood
movie.
SIERRA: In 2019, before the pandemic caused
chaos in the film industry, global box office
sales were worth roughly $42.5 billion. Of
this, the U.S. box office accounted for $11.4
billion, and China’s accounted for $9 billion.
While the U.S. was still slightly ahead, its
take had fallen from 2018, whereas China’s
had continued a long trend of growth. The
pandemic has made it difficult to measure
things accurately, but many think that China’s
market either already has, or will very soon
surpass that of the U.S., and that the trend
will only become more pronounced with time.
And, regardless, China has already become
essential to Hollywood’s bottom line, especially
when it comes to domestic flops. Consider
the 2016 film Warcraft, based on the videogame.
Warcraft: (Movie Scene)
SIERRA: It was reported that just to break
even, the film needed to gross $400 million
world wide. But in the U.S. it got panned
and only brought in $46.7 million. Not to
fear, China to the rescue! Because of the
popularity of the video game there, it had
the widest release of any film up to that
point, and pushed profits into the green with
a final total of $422 million.
TAGER: When it comes to access to the Chinese
market, the gatekeepers are government officials
that have a political agenda, there's a stick
and a carrot, right? The stick is if we don't
like your movie it won't enter. And in fact,
it's even more than that. It's if we don't
like your movie, and we think it actively
sort of insults China or insults the Chinese
government, we may punish your other movies.
We may not let your other movies in, we may
punish the studio more broadly, we may punish
the people who worked on the project more
broadly. And that really encourages a climate
of self-censorship among Hollywood professionals
who don't want to face political ramifications.
But there's also the carrot. If you sort of
play ball, you may get more favorable release
dates, you may get better terms for advertising
campaigns for the movie within the country,
and you may receive, sort of, the encouragement
of the powers that be that want your movie
to succeed within China. And so between that
carrot and the stick, studios really have
significant incentives to play ball with the
Chinese censor.
SIERRA: This carrot and stick tactic works,
even though it is hard to verify with studios.
And Hollywood does have a lot to worry about.
The list of movies banned in China is long,
and the reasons for the bans are wide-ranging.
Pirates of the Caribbean: Dead Man's Chest
was banned due to images of ghosts. Call Me
By Your Name was banned for its portrayal
of gay characters. And while it was not stated
explicitly, many suspect that the 2018 film
Christopher Robin was banned because the image
of Winnie the Pooh has been used on Chinese
social media to mock Xi Jinping. The carrot
and stick have worked so well that at this
point Hollywood is dedicating a lot of resources
to keeping its relationship with China humming
along. But it wasn’t always that way. And
you have to wonder, how did it start?
KOKAS: So, film is foundational to the Chinese
nation. 1949, the year of the founding of
the People's Republic of China, was also the
year of the founding of the Beijing Film Studios,
which at the very front gate, up until very
recently had statues of a farmer, a worker,
and a soldier, these kind of emblematic parts
of the Chinese nation. Hi, my name is Aynne
Kokas. And I'm an associate professor of Media
Studies at the University of Virginia. And
I'm a senior faculty fellow at the Miller
Center for Public Affairs. So since the beginning
of China's founding film has been central,
and we've seen all the way through the recent
years, where films like The Founding of the
Republic, The Founding of the Party, the Founding
of the Army, have been releases, supported
by the party used for the purpose of of celebrating
the growth and the development of the PRC.
SIERRA: So I know, this is a - a big question.
But what is the timeline of the Hollywood/China
relationship? Can you give us some of the
big milestones?
KOKAS: I think that we can think about a couple
of different key milestones. So there was
the growth of the fifth generation of filmmakers.
So this was kind of in the 1980s, the first
time when US filmmakers and US studios started
to take notice of Chinese filmmakers. We see
people like Zhang Yimou, coming out of the
fifth generation filmmakers, you guys may
know Zhang Yimou, from, from choreographing
the 2008, Olympic opening and closing ceremonies.
NBC Sports: We’re about to see what happens
when an artist gets nearly unlimited resources.
It’s almost a cinematic presentation playing
out in real time.
KOKAS: But he started off as a filmmaker who
made kind of art films within the Chinese
studio system in the 80s. Then we fast forward
to 1997, where there's the Hong Kong handover
from the UK to China. And this is a significant
moment in the relationship between China and
Hollywood, in the sense that we saw previously
a really robust Hong Kong film industry, and
then a shift from Hong Kong to the mainland.
SIERRA: 1997 is important for a number of
reasons. As the Hong Kong handover took place,
China also began to muscle for control over
how foreign movies portrayed their country
and its government.
TAGER: This was the year when three movies,
all from significant studios, all came out
that criticize aspects of China's government.
Two of them were on on Tibet, you had “Kundun”
and “Seven Years in Tibet”, and you had
a movie called “Red Corner” which not
only starred Richard Gere, who was kind of
a Tibet activist and of course, still is,
but already was then, but also criticizing
China's criminal justice system. The Chinese
government responded by saying that not only
would these movies never show in China, but
by saying that the people who worked on them
and the production studios would be punished
for making them, basically putting them on
an economic blacklist. In 1997, the size of
the Chinese box office was kind of the size
of the Peruvian box office, it was not a massive
economic hit that the studios were taking.
But it was when the studios were sort of put
on notice that the Chinese government would
go beyond just not letting your movie show
in their theaters if they didn't like it,
that they’d take a much more aggressive
retaliatory pose.
KOKAS: Now, where this really starts to get
going is in 2001, with China's accession into
the World Trade Organization, because this
creates some requirements for opening up the
Chinese film industry for other global box
offices. So this gets really interesting in
2012, when the US and China sign a film agreement,
which allows big budget films to enter the
Chinese market, and there to be a 34 film
floor. Now in 2017, with the Trump administration,
this all expired. And basically, there are
no rules anymore about how any of this happens
as China's market gets bigger, potentially
than the US market.
SIERRA: What would you say to a studio that
maybe leaned on the idea that they aren't
accepting Chinese censorship, they're just
trying to be more culturally sensitive and
inclusive.
KOKAS: You know, if this is really a question
of representation, show me a growth in the
number of Asian-American directors and producers
and leads in studio films, a growth in women,
a growth in, people of color, a growth in
LGBTQ folks taking leadership roles, and document
that. And then I can believe what you're saying.
TAGER: We know that Hollywood does have a
history of racist stereotypes, lack of representation,
lack of inclusion, and efforts to increase
that representation and inclusion are things
that we applaud. The Chinese censor does not
necessarily want thoughtful three dimensional
depictions of Chinese characters. What they
want is heroic self-aggrandizing depictions
of Chinese characters and -
SIERRA: Doctors saving Tony Stark type thing?
TAGER: Yeah! That is a great and literal and
specific example that actually happened. To
those who don't know what we’re referring
to, the movie “Iron Man 3”, the company
inserted Chinese-only scenes into the film
that showed in China where all of a sudden,
a series of Chinese doctors save Tony Stark's
life.
Iron Man 3: (Movie Scene)
TAGER: And that's an example of sort of how,
how proactively studios may respond to Chinese
pressure to kind of create more friendly content
in the eyes of the Chinese government.
SIERRA: Can you tell me a little bit about
the Chinese government in general because
I feel like I should probably know that while
analyzing why their involvement in Hollywood
even matters.
KOKAS: Something that's important to know
is that regulation of the film industry comes
underneath something called the State Council,
which is China's highest governing body, and
the role of the film industry has moved higher
and higher and higher in Chinese national
oversight over the past 10 years. So we've
seen from previously more local film industry
oversight, to now this State Council oversight.
What this means is that the role of the film
industry in Chinese political life is increasing
in prominence. It also means that regulations
are becoming more conservative because individual
municipalities or provinces had a little bit
more flexibility, they could do things kind
of further away from Beijing's eyes. So this
is a really important shift that we're seeing.
Xi Jinping is a known film buff. So this is
something that he he pays attention to kind
of and thinks about personally, it's also
something that has been part of Chinese national
strategies and a wide variety of different
ways.
SIERRA: Longtime Why It Matters listeners
will know that Xi Jinping has emerged as the
most powerful and assertive Chinese leader
since Mao Zedong. The special interest he
has taken in film is just a small part of
a wider strategy of asserting China’s power
on the world stage while using economic, diplomatic
and cultural leavers to try to change global
perceptions of his authoritarian regime. Xi’s
focus on censorship goes far beyond film,
including the “great firewall” that bars
Chinese citizens from accessing western platforms
like Google and Facebook.
SIERRA: So what is the Chinese model of censorship?
I mean, I know you're saying that there's
no specific list, but in general, you know,
what kind of themes and scenes get cut? And
on the same token, like, you know, what kind
of scenes do they like?
TAGER: Well, they like scenes that portray
China and its governance in a positive light,
as a leader, being sort of strong and impressive.
A great example that I would point to is 2014,
“Transformers: Age of Extinction,” which
began as a joint production with a Chinese
state owned company, The China Movie Channel.
Transformers: Age of Extinction: (Movie Scene)
KOKAS: One of the things that's really interesting
about the film is that in order to save Hong
Kong from from the Transformers, they have
to make a call to the Chinese minister of
defense in Beijing, who then sends naval ships
into Victoria Harbour in Hong Kong as a way
to assert China's protection of its national
security, vis a vis Hong Kong. And it's these
same arguments that are being used to do things
like arrest activists Joshua Wong and Agnes
Chow. So we see a Michael Bay film echoing
Chinese political discourse about its relationship
with Hong Kong, which is really strange.
TAGER: Now, a lot of observers have pointed
out that the Chinese officials in that movie
are really seen as selfless and benevolent,
particularly in their willingness to defend
Hong Kong from this alien threat. Now, the
film was released the same year as the Umbrella
Movement protests in Hong Kong calling for
greater democratic freedoms. So we can really
see the political interest of the Chinese
government in being portrayed as a benevolent,
paternalistic defender of Hong Kong from these
alien forces, at the very time that there
was a massive pro democracy movement.
SIERRA: Unlike most Chinese citizens, residents
of Hong Kong enjoyed democratic freedoms and
civil liberties for decades, even after Britain
handed the territory over to China in 1997.
But in recent years, a series of crackdowns
have made it seem like the days of Hong Kong’s
freedom are numbered. This gives an entirely
different context to a scene portraying the
Chinese navy entering Hong Kong’s harbor
in order to protect it. And to Hong Kong citizens
who are fighting to preserve their freedom,
something far more menacing than portrayals
of heroic Chinese doctors.
KOKAS: So the fact that this film was released
the weekend before July 1, which is the anniversary
of Hong Kong returning to the PRC, was really
a significant period of time.
SIERRA: Yeah, I mean, that's pretty wild,
because here in the US, most of us would have
just seen, you know, a heroic moment, we wouldn't
have noticed any of these undertones.
TAGER: But one thing I do want to note is,
I think a lot of people just assume it's sort
of the regular political messages that are
seen as out of bounds. You know, don't mention
Tibet, don't mention Taiwan, don't mention
the Dalai Lama, don't talk about the Umbrella
Protests, but the censorship system for movies
is really a lot broader than that. It really
is dynamic and censors have wide latitude
to push for the changes they want. And many
of the things that are blocked are tropes,
or genres, that, I think if you're not Chinese,
you'd be very surprised to hear about because
they just wouldn't seem political and they
wouldn't seem problematic. China's long standing
ban on ghost stories is a great example. There
are several different reasons that are given
for this, you know, the most common one is
this idea of kind of getting rid of superstition
and discouraging superstition among the populace.
However, in researching this is, there's one
body of thought that says, well, actually,
ghost stories are really much more inherently
political in China than they are in many other
countries because they were traditionally
a vehicle by which you could criticize dead
corrupt officials by portraying them as ghosts.
Time travel is another one. Time travel stories
are really kind thema non grata, to mix and
match my latin, within China and this will
affect the movies that get to be shown. “Looper”
is an interesting example. “Looper” was
a joint production and some people may recall
the movie, Bruce Willis, Joseph Gordon Levitt,
time travel was a big part of the movie. Now,
it started as the script, the movie was set
between Kansas and Paris. When Chinese financing
and Chinese co-production came in, they proposed
let's make this a joint production and let's
instead of Paris, let's film it in China.
And so one of the explanations that one of
the producers gave was, we knew it would be
hard to make a time travel movie and get it
into China so we figured, okay, if we make
the time travel movie about China in the future
and it makes China look very good, we have
a much higher chance of getting it sort of
approved to be shown within China. So this
is an example of the way that sort of business
and the political interests of the Chinese
government kind of coincide and I think there
are many business people who say, well, you
always look for the win-win. The issue here
is one of the people winning in these situations
is a government that is trying to push a specific
political narrative through film.
SIERRA: So you mentioned joint productions
with the Chinese government. Can you give
me some details on how these partnerships
work?
TAGER: So we talk about joint productions
as, almost like a tripartite relationship:
you have the foreign film making group, the
domestic filmmaking group, and then the censor
as sort of this invisible third partner. What
this does is really allow the Chinese government
a lot of leeway to influence the structure,
story, and themes of the film. And it's a
model that's growing as we speak. Particularly
as Chinese production companies become larger,
more technologically sophisticated with what
they can pull off, more significant players
in this field.
KOKAS: So this is a really interesting shift
in the dynamic. There's something called co-production,
which is essentially when Hollywood studios
go to China and try to make a film there.
And as part of that condition, they have to
give Chinese regulators oversight into the
production process. So everything from pre-production,
like, what's the idea to post production,
so final cut approval. And then there's something
that I talk about in my book “Hollywood:
Made in China” called a faux-production,
where companies try to do this, they try to
go through the process, but frankly, it's
a huge headache, having a having a Chinese
regulator, you know, check up on your on your
film production is not something that most,
you know, freewheeling Hollywood executives
would be very excited about. So sometimes
they pull back. But the part that's really
interesting is, even after pulling back, we
still see examples of potential Chinese government
influence.
SIERRA: Right. And as a viewer, you may not
even notice or realize that it's important
in some way? But you're saying it's setting
a standard and planting a seed in the people
who are viewing it.
KOKAS: Right, exactly. And I would argue,
actually, this is it's much worse when it
happens in a film like Transformers 4, than
if it happens in some kind of historical drama
where people are primed to think about questions
of politics and history and human rights.
In Transformers 4 people just want to see
the explosions, and this is kind of slipping
in underneath.
SIERRA: But there’s another recent example
that has a bit of a different story, and that’s
“Mulan”.
Mulan: (Movie Scene)
SIERRA: So I feel like part of this conversation
has to be me asking about “Mulan,” because
I remember reading a lot about “Mulan”
and some of the controversy around it. What
role does that movie play in all this?
TAGER: Yeah, so there's more than one controversy
around “Mulan,” unfortunately. And when
we did our report, we talked about the fact
that the star of “Mulan,” Chinese-American
actress Crystal Liu, she made several comments
being supportive of the Hong Kong police during
a wave of Hong Kong pro democracy protests.
And one of the interesting things about that
was how there appeared to be a government-backed
social media campaign against the Hong Kong
protests under the hashtag #SupportMulan.
So it was literally a government-backed messaging
narrative campaign using Mulan and Crystal
Liu’s comment to push a political message.
KOKAS: It was so shocking to see that the
Chinese that the film itself that “Mulan”
was actually echoing a lot of Chinese government
discourse, a lot of Chinese government language
about how it's necessary to quash Western
rebellions as they were filming in Xinjiang,
this site that the Chinese government deems
its site of Western rebellion. So there's
a whole history of the Chinese government
having difficulties with minorities in the
west of China. So we think about Tibet, we
think about Xinjiang, because these were places
that had, you know, long histories and traditions
separate from the Han Chinese tradition. And
in “Mulan” what we saw was this valorization
of Chinese imperial culture, and the treatment
of minorities in the west of China as barbarians,
who needed to be quashed, and Disney made
that film. And they made it in sites where
there are concentration camps for Uighurs.
SIERRA: For those who don’t know, the situation
in China's northwestern Xinjiang province
is often cited as the most shocking sign of
China’s growing authoritarianism under Xi
Jinping. The region is the site of detention
camps where more than a million members of
the Muslim Uyghur minority are subjected to
population control, forced labor, torture,
sexual abuse, family separation and repression
of cultural and religious expression. The
Chinese government, for its part, has denied
that the abuses are taking place, despite
the fact that they have been documented by
experts, journalists, survivors and government
officials.
TAGER: At the credits of the movie, they literally
thank several government agencies that are
either actively involved in or propagandizing
against the human rights abuses that are going
on as we speak, in Xinjiang -- again, the
internment of over a million Muslims there.
And the revelation that the film has scenes
that were shot presumably very close to where
these internment centers are, and that the
movie sort of went out of its way to thank
these people who are involved in human rights
abuses, is genuinely deeply troubling.
KOKAS: There were boycotts related to this
issue as well as the Hong Kong issue and the
only time that Disney kind of spoke publicly
about this in the period immediately following
its release was a discussion by the CFO who
was talking about, you know, issues with the
film, presumably related to its financial
performance.
SIERRA: So nothing about the human rights
abuses happening right next to their film
sites?
KOKAS: Not explicitly. It should be noted
that in an official response, Disney insisted
that it filmed in Xinjiang for “authenticity”,
and that their inclusion of thanks to Chinese
authorities in the credits was in keeping
with standard practices. Listeners can find
their full response in the shownotes.
TAGER: I think that is emblematic of the larger
attitude that Hollywood as an industry has
taken towards this issue, which is, you know,
they don't see much they don't see any upside
to them dealing with it, they're under significant
economic imperatives to play ball with the
Chinese government, and they see engaging
in this issue further as a lose-lose proposition,
and they'd like everyone to just kind of move
on and they hope that the issue sort of goes
away. In fact, we expect that it will become
worse for studios that the pressures on them
to comply with these censorship strictures
will become more and more intense, given how
the Chinese box office is simply becoming
more and more important to studios, and conversely,
that the domestic filmmakers and filmmaking
students in China are becoming more and more
able to pull off big blockbuster movies. So
Chinese film-going audiences need Hollywood
less than less to get their fix of a blockbuster
spectacle. But Hollywood as an industry needs
access to Chinese audiences more and more.
KOKAS: So I think that this demonstrates the
challenge that the US faces over the next
20 to 30 years. The US system is very focused
on global profitability and we have a lot
of companies that are, you know, listed on
our stock exchanges that need to continue
growing and the way that they continue growing
is through expanding global markets. China
is a really important global market. So it's,
in some ways an existential question about
the US system. To what degree do we continue
prioritizing economic growth and economic
growth in China? and to what degree do we
take into account these other issues?
SIERRA: What's the price we pay as a society
for allowing a repressive regime to sorta
shape the types of media we produce, and even
the stories we tell?
TAGER: The cost will never be fully visible,
and that's exactly the problem, right? The
largest cost of this will be the movies that
never get made, or that never gets written
or filmed in the first place. This space for
storytelling will narrow. And Hollywood is
the world's largest storytelling center. And
where Hollywood goes on this, so go other
storytelling centers. I mean, Hollywood is
not the only film industry that is being affected
by this. So other film centers in the world
Europe, India, Nigeria, as just examples,
they having far less resources and access
to, say, cutting edge technology than Hollywood
does, if Hollywood is not going to stand up
to this influence, it's hard for us to expect
other smaller film centers to do so. So what
we're talking about is a global shaping of
the perhaps the most important storytelling
medium that's ever existed to date, which
is movies. And the movies that people consume
influence their perception of what's going
on in the world. So the idea that those movies
by and large would be influenced systemically
by an autocratic government is something that
I'm not overstating when I say could have
global consequences.
SIERRA: So would the US government ever step
in something like this? Should they?
KOKAS: I mean, I think that there's not a
there's not a big place for it. And let's
be honest, like anytime the US government
has gotten involved in the film industry,
and in the past of the US, it hasn't really
turned out that well, we don't want, like,
a new McCarthy era. I think that there are
a couple of things that can be done in terms
of just like tracing financial transactions,
requiring more reporting about who's funding
what and that's something that I think studios
can do and the US government can require that
doesn't necessarily lead to the senators deciding
what types of content gets produced in Hollywood,
because that's a lose-lose.
TAGER: You know, as a matter of general principle,
we're very leery of the idea of having governmental
intervention to save free speech from governmental
intervention, right? This is an area where
anyone who's looking into a potential governmental
or legislative solution on the US side should
step pretty gingerly. And it really underscores
the fact that what's best is if the industry
on its own, takes unified and affirmative
action on this. Both to protect their own
interests, and because it just is objectively
a better idea in terms of free speech and
artistic expression to act before government
figures, either rightly or wrongly feel like
they need to act instead. Right? That's why
one of our recommendations, is has been a
voluntary disclosure mechanism that we think
the industry should take on in a unified at
large way, were somewhat similar to what Silicon
Valley does, where they kind of periodically
post their takedown requests they've received
from governments around the world and we think
that there's a model there that could be followed
from Hollywood as an industry being like,
these are the censorship requests we've received
from around the world.
SIERRA: Do you think that more disclosure
of how these decisions are made would help
this whole process along and sort of bring
it to light and then, you know, we could we
could clean it up and get it taken care of?
KOKAS: I mean, I think that's really difficult,
right? Because a lot of these are creative
processes. So it's just as easy to say that
this is just the kind of creative vision of
these directors. And that's not something
that I think we want to start trampling on
within the US context, which is why I think
following the money is a way that I feel more
comfortable with. So, you know, maybe we set
limits on the amount of funding that can come
from certain firms. Or maybe we set limits
on certain firms that can invest in Hollywood
studio productions. That would be kind of
as far as I would feel comfortable going.
And I think that we also need to have conversations
like this so that consumers have an understanding
of how these market systems operate. And maybe
push back on those more broadly.
TAGER: One of the things we talk about in
our report as a recommendation is we would
love to see American studios and filmmaking
communities do more to encourage and partner
with independent Chinese filmmakers, who often
are underground or exiled if they don't want
to participate in the censorship regime. We
applaud cultural interchange and we always
want to see more of it. And we don't want
anyone to listen to, to this recording, or
to read our report and think, oh, the solution
is like, let's spend less time talking about
Chinese themes or let’s just -
SIERRA: Don't do anything with China ever
again, right?
TAGER: We want cultural interchange, the problem
occurs when the sole gatekeepers to that cultural
interchange use it as an opportunity to apply
politically motivated censorship. So we encourage
anyone who works in the film world to do what
they can to work with Chinese filmmakers and
tell Chinese stories, but we encourage them
to do so in whatever way they can to avoid
or to push back against this type of censorship.
At the end of the day, we believe that sunlight
remains the best disinfectant. Hollywood enjoys
a reputation of being willing to speak truth
to power here at home and by home, I refer
to the United States. To the point where you
have some Americans who are like, my goodness,
these unpatriotic Hollywood figures, right?
But they have that reputation of being willing
to speak truth to power. We think that Hollywood
as an industry has been less vocal on this
issue when it comes to censorship in the Chinese
government than it has been in making sure
to push back against any attempted censorship
from the United States government. We're asking
for the same standard that Hollywood applies
as an industry to its own relationship with
governmental figures here in the United States
in protecting artistic freedom. We're asking
them to apply that same standard to its relationships
with other governments around the world.
SIERRA: China’s box office is only going
to grow, and it may seem impossible to dissuade
Hollywood from a profit motive that strong.
But still, in recent years the American public
has demonstrated its power to force Hollywood
to make incremental progress on other issues.
Moviegoers have been increasingly vocal about
representations of gender and race, and Hollywood
has begun to realize that ignoring these concerns
can come at a cost. It would be good, perhaps,
if “appeasing authoritarian governments
and human rights abusers” was added to that
list. But to make this happen audiences need
to become more literate about what’s going
on in the rest of the world. Understanding
the situation in Hong Kong, or in Xinjiang,
can help you read between the lines and see
the true cost of censorship. The United States
still has a lot of soft power, and Hollywood
is one of the best examples of how that power
touches the world. We would never accept censorship
from our own government, why should we accept
it from any other? For resources used in this
episode and more information, visit CFR.org/Whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes. Have a
question or some feedback? Feel like saying
hey? Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
AND, please please, if you are a fan of the
show, show us some love! Give us five stars
and leave a review on Apple podcasts. It means
so much to us and it helps us get noticed.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations. The show is created
and produced by Jeremy Sherlick, Asher Ross,
and me, Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound designer
is Markus Zakaria. Robert McMahon is our Managing
Editor, and Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital
Officer. Original music is composed by Ceiri
Torjussen. Extra research was provided by
Senniah Mason. Special thanks go to Richard
Haass and Jeff Reinke.
For Why It Matters this is Gabrielle Sierra
signing off. See you soon!